I don't think it's enough just to love
it and then just to do it and go out and
win it
it's not that simple you need to have
structured goals you need to tell
yourself okay what are my goals for the
short-term what are my goals for the
long-term now that I've accomplished
almost everything and I'm supposed to go
out on the tennis court singing let's
just play free it's just hit the ball
who cares you know but this is not how
you're gonna win matters because it
comes down to margins and you have to be
so clear in your mind exactly what you
want to do and what you want to achieve
and for me it doesn't work without any
goals without any targets I cannot
compete properly I don't like to think
too far ahead so you haven't taught I
don't like to get too far ahead people
say it like goals long distance goals
and [ __ ] that's too much for me I
already feel like I'm living it and then
I just carry on the own that you know
carry on day by day already living the
final goal the goal of being the world
champion I already carry myself like I'm
my world champ and I already speak like
I'm a world champion and and that's it I
just carry on day by day so I'll take it
as a calms my intention with this video
was to spread understanding not fighting
I want you to see that it's not one
point of view or the other you can pull
and learn from both especially the one
that you don't immediately resonate with
embrace the genius of the end